[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie huge news
they just had the European version of
CinemaCon they screened Avengers 4 and
Captain Marvel footage and it is
game-changer so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video the big news is is
they screened a scene between ant-man
and Iron Man where ant-man explains to
Iron Man that they have technology that
will allow them to go into different
realities and grab the Infinity stones
so this has got like one layer deep also
it syncs up with what Evangeline Lilly
the wasp said recently when she said
that Avengers 4 feels a lot like lost
season 4 that was the season where you
got to see multiple realities the
technology that ant-man is talking about
is obviously something that we're
probably going to learn about during
ant-man and the wasp in what have we
seen in all of those trailers this is
where Kevin Feige sort of brings it all
together and says aha see what we did
there so the ghost phases through
different dimensions because she was
blasted with energy from the quantum
realm we unleashed something powerful we
call her to ghost she could destroy the
world
you know I'm an Avenger now so there's
this big accident during ant-man of the
wasp you've seen in the trailers she
gets her powers but part of that idea is
is that if she phases through different
dimensions she's essentially crossing
over into other realities while she's
walking around on our earth we've all
seen the scenes with Hulk Iron Man
Captain America in his original Avengers
costume with ant-man standing there they
all have really weird devices on their
wrists we're like what do those do
they're all wearing them maybe it has
something to do with them traveling back
into time it sounds like these devices
are what enable them to travel into the
alternate realities if this description
of the footage is correct now obviously
they're probably not going to screen
this anytime soon they're not in any
rush to release any trailers but the
Russos did say when these pictures
leaked out a long time ago that hey you
know this is something that we did
during civil war so they were implying
that it was the be ar effing technology
so it might be happening in these scenes
here like just to give it more context
now with all this new information in the
footage is is that Iron Man uses the be
AR effing technology to learn where the
gems are
they need to get them so they'd have to
search their memories they plan their
heist then they go into the alternate
realities and if you've heard chris
hemsworth recent comments about how
avengers 4 is supposed to be even more
shocking than infinity war more shocking
than half of all life being erased in
the universe them dimension-hopping rick
and morty style through time and space
to their previous adventures in
alternate realities to grab Infinity
stones certainly fits that bill so if
you're not a big Rick and Morty fan they
travel through dimensions they don't
travel through time but imagine through
their actions Iron Man in the Avengers
Cronenberg the MCU so what is Rick
Sanchez's plan of last resort the most
extreme scenario he just bails reality
where things aren't so bad this makes
you think of all kinds of Doctor Strange
multiverse twists there's been two
movies where they've specifically called
out the idea of the multiverse
there's Doctor Strange where he legit
travelled through all those different
dimensions then during ant-man the wasp
when he goes into the Microverse they
call it the quantum realm because the
Microverse is a marvel thing but
somebody else owns that IP I think it's
Hasbro because the micronauts are the
characters that belong to the Microverse
and they own the rights to do a
micronauts movie so that's why Marvel is
calling the Microverse of the MCU the
quantum realm but that's what it is
there are things that are alive down
there it's an alternate source of energy
obviously something blasts the ghost to
give her her abilities but doesn't it
all make sense why ant-man and the wasp
is happening between Avengers infinity
war and Avengers 4 and how Kevin Feige
is so smart and getting people to go see
it like oh you know just a fun adventure
something to lighten the mood after that
real bummer of an ending during infinity
war but also there's a really important
concept that we're going to be using
during Avengers 4
that you won't really understand unless
you go to see ant-man the wasp so aha
see what they did there in that also
like them going to alternate realities
can explain how they would incorporate
Fox x-men IP because you've done so many
things teasing the multiverse wouldn't
it make sense that they would close down
the first 10 years of Marvel movies by
actually showing you how crazy things
can get in these alternate realities
like oh hey see this thing over here
that you never thought that we'd do in a
movie well it's happening over in this
alternate universe and I know a lot of
you are asking about this new Comcast
twist in the Disney Foxx deal so if
you're not sure what's going on why
people were freaking out this morning
AT&T is buying Time Warner there was
this big lawsuit the government was
trying to stop it from happening and
blocked the merger the merger went
through so part of the reason why Fox
was going to sell to Disney is because
they didn't think that there would be
any big regulatory problems from the
government a little while ago comcast
had already made an offer like this is a
chart for the history of the Disney
Comcast Fox deal comcast made an offer
Fox said you know what we think there's
going to be some problems with this the
government might block it Disney stepped
in with more money on the table but it
was in stock form so it wasn't like cash
that they were just passing across in a
giant bag across the table but because
of what happened during this 18t Time
Warner deal comcast is no longer afraid
of the government blocking the deal so
they came back to the table with Fox
made an offer for even more cash so
listen to how crazy this deal is so
right off the bat it's 65 billion in
cash comcast is offering 19 percent more
money than Disney is so in addition to
that on top of that sixty five billion
dollars they're giving them they're also
going to pay an additional two and a
half billion dollars in case the
government comes in later and breaks the
deal up even more about 1.5 billion
dollars to pay to Disney for Fox having
to break their arrangement because as of
right now the Fox Disney deal is almost
done like they're getting ready to sign
paper on Inc so because they're
currently closing so if Fox wants to
back out they have to pay a penalty fee
which Comcast would foot the bill for
because they're the ones that are coming
in trying to get Fox to break the deal
with Disney so Walter
old Comcast is trying to give Fox 70
billion dollars in order for them to
break their deal with Disney but Disney
has not countered with a different offer
yet that was supposed to be a meeting so
what everyone is expecting to happen is
as the Disney will come back to the
table so sweeten the deal just a little
bit and it'll drag things out which is
why you know people said that you know
even if the Disney deal goes through
with Fox then it wouldn't close until
the end of summer next year that's how
long it would have taken originally had
Comcast not stepped in now it might take
even longer than that which is why when
Kevin Feige was talking about Avengers 4
stuff he said I'm waiting by the phone
for someone to tell me when I can use
the x-men characters I've already done a
video about that because he said a whole
bunch of other stuff about Avengers 4
because he said we would see alternate
versions of characters that we already
know doesn't that also make you think of
multiverse like oh wow they are really
doubling down on this idea so let me
know in the comments what do you think
about the concept of the Avengers
instead of just straight-up trying to
steal the gauntlet in the gems from
Thanos in our reality going to multiple
other realities to assemble a gauntlet
that way if you're big comic book reader
you're also probably wondering wait a
minute are they changing the comics
because the gems from other realities
don't work in our own reality in fact
there was an infinity prime countdown
comic book that just addressed this with
the collector in the Grand Master they
have the reality gem but they bring in
Peter quill to see why it won't work he
can't figure it out like okay this is
clearly an infinity stone why isn't it
doing anything then file a Vell who's
the daughter of Marvel from another
reality ports in takes it and explains
it's not working for you because this is
the gem from my reality and then
promptly returned to her own reality
with it the only real answer I have for
that is that the MCU has never really
cared about the particular zuv those
kinds of comic book details so I
wouldn't be surprised if they change
that for the movie because right now
that's the only way to explain how this
twist would work then going to alternate
reality is grabbing different gems from
all over the multiverse and then using
that to make it a gauntlet but we all
know that they can forge another one
because Eitri has the mold sitting at
the space Forge so what will happen is
is is we get new information I will
totally do videos about everything I'm
not
acting any of this footage to post
online they also screen captain marvel
footage but it was mostly behind the
scenes because they haven't quite
finished filming that yet that will
probably be released later this year
maybe a comic-con maybe sometime before
October but the Kids Choice Awards is on
Monday so I'm expecting something to
post then maybe an Aquaman trailer
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner just B channel please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for that Avengers for
Kevin Feige teaser and click here for
the Wonder Woman too teaser take you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]